[Applause]
i would love to get an answer for how
it's all working and
exactly what is going on down there
these are highly social animals maybe
even more than we ever
comprehended that is one of the many
remarkable scenes from
secrets of the whales a new documentary
and book
the documentary was executive produced
by james cameron
voiced by sigourney weaver and features
the photography and adventures of brian
scary scary has been diving to document
life under the sea for more than four
decades
wait until you see what he came up with
this time his most
ambitious project to date
so much of this process for you is is
the waiting
it is waiting and patience is probably
the most important tool oh my goodness
whoa
right there on the whale watching trips
that leave the new england aquarium
you're guaranteed to see a whale or you
get a rain check for a future tour
oh there you go what you're not
guaranteed is a chance to spend a day
with brian scary getting ready to fluke
the man who may have spent more time up
close with these creatures
than anyone else on the planet whales
are the world's most intelligent giants
scary's latest project took him three
years
to 24 locations from the equator to the
poles
the result secrets of the whales a
four-part documentary that features some
of the most fascinating underwater
moments
we've ever seen at the aquarium where
scary as an explorer in residence
he gave us a special screening this one
female
adult orca came in and you know was sort
of checking me out
since we can go back in theaters now
right figure this is the right way to do
it
it is that includes scary's encounter
with an orca
who seems to offer him a stingray for
lunch
i'm swimming toward this animal and i
see her coming toward me with this ray
hanging out of her mouth and i'm
thinking here it is this is the moment
and then she drops it
so i'm thinking i lost it and then i
went down and i knelt on the bottom
and she comes back orcas which some call
killer whales may be the most dangerous
hunter in the ocean
but in this case the whale appeared to
be treating scary like a member of the
family
maybe that's because he kind of is you
said if you could spend time with
only one animal it would be whales when
you're working with whales it's a whole
different level
it's it's you know there's a high degree
of cognition
and those animals are truly allowing you
into their worlds if
if you were interacting with them
[Music]
scary has been free diving for decades
to photograph
all kinds of life under the sea his
pictures have been featured on the cover
of national geographic
multiple times but for this latest
documentary and book
he had to rethink a lot of what he knew
about the planet's largest animals
one of the emerging themes that i sort
of
uh settled on was this notion of culture
the fact that these animals have this
rich
ancestral traditions they as they
announce where i mean
where they're from when they meet whales
from other places yeah
so the researchers in in the caribbean
that are studying
sperm whales say that the first thing a
whale that spends time around dominica
says when it meets another whale is
i am from dominica
[Music]
secrets of the whale spends a lot of
time showing some truly endearing
whale family dynamics how mothers teach
calves to swim and eat
[Music]
how whales communicate across thousands
of miles
even sing it's activity that's taken
place for tens of millions of years
but one that's been under increasing
pressure in the last couple hundred
for much of the 19th and 20th century
whales were prized for their fat that
was used in lamps
soap and cosmetics and whales were
killed by the thousands
whales overall were in a pretty bad
place in the 1970s
how much better has it gotten well it's
kind of a double-edged sword so
whale populations have increased you
know animals like humpbacks have come
back
the downside is that the oceans in
general
have been degraded so you know we're
dumping 18 billion pounds of plastic
into the ocean in
in every year we've taken 90 percent of
the big fish out of the ocean in the
last 60 years
climate changes destroying the prey that
they eat
so although whaling has ceased in many
places and their populations are
increasing
the overall picture is not particularly
good working solo
is just as effective but they've chosen
to perform as a group
in secrets of the whales the animals of
course are the stars
only today they have a dedicated fan
trying to track them down but scary's
supporting role
is crucial national geographic explorer
and world famous
whale photographer brian scary do you
just keep listening to sigourney weaver
introduce you
yeah i pretty much have that on a loop
in my home so my kids love that part
it's great right exactly scary's work on
documenting ocean life
is continuing he's working on his next
national geographic project documenting
changes to the gulf of maine
one of the fastest warming spots on
earth recently he captured this drone
video of two endangered right whales off
cape cod
appearing to hug right there oh yeah
our trip to the tip of cape cod was
scary was not as rigorous as his
three-year expedition but for just a few
hours on the water
not too shabby oh right wait whoa nice
whoa sweet he likes us
i think so yeah today was successful i
mean
it was we got cookies we had minkies
fins
and a friendly humpback a very friendly
humpback
yeah so either you're good luck or we're
good luck i think it's you
awesome oh man that is just
beautiful we know it's brian of course
who's who's the luck
it's one thing seeing the whales in a
book or on the tv screen it's another to
see them
up close in person just incredible they
look incredible there
yeah not too shabby jeff i think that's
your tagline
now he's having a good day quickly you
can see more of brian scary's work at
natgeo.complanetpossible
and we want to thank nachio for letting
us see more of brian's amazing work and
the new england aquarium
for giving us that access